hello welcome back to big mood it is a
mood in here because this is the first
time ever between our two podcasts that
we've ever done we've ever had male
guests yeah the show were the first men
yeah and you are the first men so we
often get requests from the audience we
have been for a while now of what a
guy's perspective would be on the topics
that we've covered because we do a lot
of like oh well here's how I lock down a
man or here's how how we dated when we
were single but you would never hear
from the guys on like what they liked or
didn't like and so we thought it would
be cool to hear from you guys seeing as
though you lock down two of the most
gorgeous window on the planet I've seen
hotter but yes I won't tell you at home
cuz you're very vindictive I don't know
what you mean Steve I cook your dinners
though so maybe be careful what do you
got my nikki you don't got anything like
that just talking [ __ ] because we like
to talk [ __ ] to each other and then [ __ ]
it out later that's our style chewy
stimulated her sea area we're just
getting started we're very very cold
right now oh my god touch each other so
guys whatever all right so just just to
introduce um I'm Nikki limo I'm Tiffany
I'm Steve green achill someone call me
Iceman no one calls in hi Stacey
and we've talked about you guys a lot on
our show before just so the audience
knows it's just tuning in I belong to
this one yeah and belongs to Kasey
Iceman and Nikki not the other way
around they also have their own channels
and stuff that you can definitely check
out the links are in the description and
I am doing one live show called house
Lords
coming very soon at the end of this
month no one asked well I just wanted to
promo okay let's get into this because
I'm very curious we did talk about
Steve's low body count earlier before we
started how low just to be clear about
what that means your virgin level but
we'll talk about it anyway well actually
I got virgins beat okay multiples I will
say by multiples so have Casey is your
body count lower did you get to have a
ho phase that you dated over I always
try to have a ho phase you always got to
try to have a home you're just trying to
have a whole phase but honestly it never
goes that's according to plan you
usually get a body count of like one or
two and then buy the one or two you're
like they're player [ __ ] he's like yeah
you me one or two you fall completely in
love and you guys were making fun of me
Sam near Birds level and he's like I get
around I do some [ __ ] up for sure you
have a higher body count than I do
though do i yeah cuz I've never had a
whole face oh sure I mean I think like
college in like you know when you go to
college and you do like and having moved
out to LA and there's like no you're
just meeting new people that you know
reestablish the one-night stands yes I
do have experience with the one-night
stand
oh come on you know too because I feel
like there's a pressure out there for
people to have a whole phase and like
and there's also a stigma that's like oh
guys would rather sleep around and not
they don't want a relationship as badly
girls are always the one that want the
relationship but is so false though
right right I feel like it the the whole
phase like it feels lonely it really
does and it doesn't it doesn't make you
feel more confident about yourself after
a one-night stand I don't think
we're players but like not everybody
yeah yeah I think I definitely know guy
friends that like they'll never settle
down they've already made it clear that
they're always gonna be a bachelor for
life and they definitely want to like
chase tail every single day only as men
we know they're always the kind of guys
that are like what do you guys up to
this weekend you wanna hang out because
but that's how they get their energy
that excited I don't think I could knock
them either for like for like oh you're
not gonna ever find happiness if you're
gonna be lonely for the rest of your
life but I think that they're like that
I'm just saying that's a coincidence
for you what that because of the other
like that well because I've seen a lot
of that man with with dudes and I'm sure
some guys can make it work but I've
never felt lower probably ever than
having a one-night stand and then the
next day being like damn I'm into this
chick you know I'm saying and that and
then I tried to make it like a thing for
like a couple weeks yeah it just wasn't
sticking I could not develop feelings
for this person so what um because
between like a one-night stand
and someone that you wiped up what made
you not into that girl but into me I
think it was uh she I don't know man
like like you are fun and funny and
thank you would you have a take on
something it's interesting and this
individual did not know she was yeah
just very surface level conversations
nothing that went too deep
yeah and that that's not fun for me I
like to really explore things and and I
like to hear different perspectives and
not just people regurgitating what I'm
saying right yeah I mean challenge I
love that yeah stimulated yes it's it's
very similar yeah yeah yeah cuz then i
also wonder too like what's the case for
most guys like do most guys I know you
guys have the male mind and you have
other male friends like do you guys
actually talk about things like this cuz
girls do like we talk about what we look
for in men but and we are all different
tastes and styles and stuff but yeah I'm
curious with with guys with my with with
my boys we do I
we talk about relationship time yeah
when we when we are together me Joe
Barton case we all we like check in with
each other to like it's really helpful
especially if you're gonna be creative
together it's helpful to like kind of
connect
yeah connect just so that you can be
like get all that stuff out so that you
can then be creative after and so it's
it's great to do that and I recommend it
to all guys out there to check in with
each other I know girls do it much
easier yeah typically it was a little
bit more difficult I've heard for men to
open up because a lot of men weren't
raised to open up yeah that's true you
know hopefully as a friend group once
Steve which was injected into our guy
circle like we were a lot more emotional
than we ever been like I think with like
me Barton Joe specifically like we've
never really opened up about
relationships as much until you came in
but but it wasn't it was weird too it's
like it's not like we had locker room
talk all the time either where we're
talking about chicks and tits and things
like that just kind of like Matt's like
some [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and let's talk
about I would you see the fight or you
see this or like what you make you make
that steak I was good huh I'll talk
about that but then once Steve came into
their friend circle yeah we opened up a
lot more and we're like all like
sensitive now in feelings well I mean it
helps with your relationships to like
you know personally I know that like you
know the running theme from the couples
was like relationships take so much work
and work and work and work and then we
realize it you guys you know like there
was a lack of vulnerability and opening
it up and like it's not because you want
to but maybe because you didn't know how
you don't know how and you don't think
it's it's it's it's sexy it's not it's
not cool tomato it's not manly but I
think it's the same for women too I feel
like there's like this weird like like
social thing that it's like you don't
want to be vulnerable I think that's the
word it's not necessarily not sexy but
it's just you don't want to be
vulnerable I know when you're at the
moment you're vulnerable like you're
this week yeah woman won't think you can
protect her anymore or something like
that
exactly exactly I get what you're saying
too on the women's side because then if
we're being vulnerable and like really
telling you what we're thinking what I'm
talking about the girls that end up
being very passive-aggressive like these
kind of you're talking about that guy
that kind of sure yeah like how they
they just can't even open up and like
yeah there's a good idea that like men
don't want vulnerable women either like
just don't complain about anything don't
you know don't tell me about your life
you know just just shut up so I think on
both aspects of both genders I think
there's that we each have our own
reasons why we don't want to be
vulnerable and I think that I think and
there's a lot of people there's a lot a
people who also do that whole thing
where it's like I don't want to deal
with your [ __ ] enough [ __ ] I don't want
to deal with your [ __ ] like come on
figure your stuff out whatever we just
so backwards because understanding your
partner on a deeper level and like what
their language is and the way they
process emotions is so important to
communication because then when you do
have an issue you're able to communicate
to your partner the way that they
understand it the way that they process
things more harmless and like it
actually like a symptom by it
symbiotic I think yeah that venom by oh
[Laughter]
but yeah that's what I mean like it
works together like because without
communication or vulnerability then
there's no way the other person will
even get to know you and you know what
I've realized recently for myself is
that I didn't know myself very well and
so how could I like put myself out there
for our marriage and stuff if I don't
even know who I am or even like love and
respect myself and like how do I expect
you to do the same to me so that to me
has been like a lot of self-discovery
where I feel like it's helped our
marriage a lot that's hard work to do
inside of a marriage already when you
are inside a marriage like now I'm gonna
try to find myself just a family yeah
right stuff dude yeah when you're
already a wife and a mother and then
you're like I think I should figure out
who I am that is that's tough
yeah sure but I'm so proud of you cuz
you really have done a lot of
self-discovery and like I see this like
brand-new yeah I think it's so important
and I wish like everything that I am
learning now if I could have known that
before even entering such a serious like
long-term like a marriage you know cuz
this is a type of work that needs to be
done before you commit like because we
are our Road has been bumpy as hell it
certainly would be ideal but I feel like
better late than never feel like sure
good thing that you understand that and
you were like working on it so that's
awesome and then you guys figure that
out in the first year well I have had
the I guess advantage of always being
kind of a loner like so I you know used
to stay at home alone and then I lived
alone for three years of like I don't
want a date you know I mean I don't want
it to be in a relationship I want to
figure it out and I want to live alone I
want to have my own happiness in my own
life and it's always during those times
when you get locked down into the
marriage the relationship that you're
gonna end up marrying I was like love is
the cold dead lie told by thieves I'm
never gonna date I'm never gonna marry
anybody I don't give a [ __ ] and then I'm
I was with Nikki within like nine days
of that yeah same for us it's like we
were both trying to hoe it out yeah we
were like we're gonna be a fling don't
don't get too close
yeah that might be is that like oh I'm
good on my own like I had a relationship
to keep me happy and then that's it sexy
when it's like wow you're really
independent you really I got your [ __ ]
together that's I want to be with that
and that's when that's when the person
that you're gonna be with ends up
walking into your life yeah it's like
when the universe is like okay now
you're ready here yeah it just you just
have to make sure that you allow the
right person in because if they don't
have their [ __ ] together and they're
just attracted to that you've got your
[ __ ] together they're gonna drag you
down and I think that the timing was
right for us
at least yes but then you also were
extremely doped because he already I
mean we were both going through breakups
but you had like an eight month leg up
on me and so I had just come out of one
and I was yeah this this is something
that sounds lame but it's very true I
missed my dog man I lost my dog in the
break-up and I loved that dog and that
was that was a toughy because I knew
there's some people who do this like we
can share custody of the animal or
whatever I couldn't I couldn't do that
it was too much like I have to see this
person to see the the dog so he was just
like clean break goodbye see and no
goodbyes either like no like moment of
like I'm having my goodbye moment I
can't do that I had to just do stuff
yeah that's right so that was hard and I
didn't even really face that I was going
through that until probably six months
later I remember I remember Nicky got it
out of me
cuz I I didn't even know yeah I knew
that I missed the dog but I didn't know
that was such a big deal he's just upset
all the time and like he would blame it
on other things like Oh traffic he Oh
like I have work to do or like whatever
but it was like a deep deep upsetness
and we really had to like dig for that
one but one thing that you learn when
you're alone is you know what it smells
nice to you hygiene yeah taking care of
yourself and what better way than an
organic do directly not that other
antiperspirant stuff that's gonna get
into your armpit right some harm to your
body
yeah so that's why you gotta check out
native so it's safe it's formulated
without aluminum parabens or talk it's
also vegan and it's never ever tested on
animals so it's made with ingredients
that you've actually heard of like
coconut oil and shea butter and it
actually works so it's it's a really
great deal right and it also smells it
smells so good
smells delicious look this one that we
have right here is lavender and rose
look at that smell that smells so good
you could literally smell like your
favorite candle yeah
so they have with over 10 cent 10 cents
like you know like not not money but
like sense if I smelled like that would
you want to bone more it should make
native candles good smell
yeah they even have classics and
rotating seasonals so you can be
guarantee that you will find what you
love and so oh man I can't stop some
like this
they also have it for men if you guys
are interested I would wear that scent
right there yeah smells good yeah men
women even teens so as of right now you
can get 20% off your first purchase by
visiting native deodorant comm and using
promo code big mood your checkout so
again that's 20% off your first purchase
visit native comm such I'm sorry native
deodorant calm and use promo code big
mode during checkout is a big mood it is
a big mood honestly this is uh I could
clearly say this is my favorite scent it
smells so delish rose yeah that's a good
one
alright well make sure you wear that
make sure you wear some deodorant when
you're going on dates let's talk about
that part for a little bit like how was
your dating experience it was good when
you said about boning and deodorant I
was like dude do people ever put
deodorant in their taint area yes I used
to do that when I was younger but I've
never asked my partners if they'd like
I'd ever paid off or like if it was more
enjoyable down there jackhammering you
[Applause]
smell good down there actually because
now I'm curious Steve does wash his dick
before anything happens always that's
good and and he has a delightful
smelling body gentle whatever you shower
gel thank you a nice I think I've only
noticed if someone didn't smell good yes
you don't want that
and it's very much sticks with you oh
yeah and it taints their relationship if
you will
true I mean it shortens every step of
the way up until sex right just you
don't want to be yeah yeah that's true
it's pretty nasty have you ever been
down there all smell and have you ever
been down there and the area is not
groomed whatsoever in any way at all
like it's a secret garden down there you
don't mind that he's [ __ ] nasty
you know what skis I've ever experienced
that like the reason why I'm saying that
and not nasty like throwing you under
the bus it's kind of like you're kinky
like that like oh yeah like you know I
won't shower for a couple days and then
he's just he likes that is the
pheromones pheromones are stronger than
the whatever but you don't even happy Oh
though like I don't I don't ever smell
like anything that's unsavory to me
yeah it's like it's it's always it
smells sweet you always say it's
strawberry milkshake yes
yeah melted strawberry ice have you
sweat man Nikki sweat is literally sweet
yeah right you called me a Glade plugin
no cuz I don't know anytime that you
smell bet and she's always like oh I
forgot to put on deodorant today or
whatever and she'll like do that and I'm
like I can't smell like wasn't in here
it's true we say like when you are
turned on by the fair like the person's
natural scent like that's your chemistry
is supposed to really work together like
if you if you're turned off by that you
might have a relative in your bloodline
like it might be some sort of like same
gene pool that you're not supposed to
make always a how that works yeah like
it's to protect you naturally about the
incest people they don't they just don't
smell it I don't know it's Mel's and
then the P n and their brother or sister
they're like mmm
I had a guy that I dated for a little
bit and he was very physically
attractive on the outside like
traditionally physically attractive like
did we get it he smells like sour milk
no I couldn't get over it and it's dim
please go on and I think it's just like
to me he smelled like sour milk but
maybe if he met someone that way he was
supposed to meet with like they he was
related yeah cuz he was the only half
Filipino guy that I dated there you go
so maybe something he was eating because
like I think for me like I have i create
sense that really really hates and some
when I eat like extra onion extra garlic
at the Korean barbeque she doesn't smell
the Korean barbeque like that smoke
flavor she smells more of the kimchi
garlicky like it's not the actual food
cuz like those foods alone I like the
way they smell but then it's like the
way it's processed out of your pores I'm
just like oh my gosh we need to do
something about this right you're a
surfer moans oh I love oh thank you they
haven't you're not the first girl to
point that out though it's like I was
with yeah but they pointed out the the
kimchi smell - it's like yes it's not
like like you're the only one maybe it
was like the cultural thing like you
know maybe if you dated another Asian
girl she wouldn't mind and because I'm
Mexican
she smells no matter who he is true
you're like yeah cuz my the Mexican guys
don't mind if I smell like beans
universally smelly thing that is also
kind of delicious yeah true my kimchi no
I've never seen kimchi that's why I also
know that that you guys love it and I
know that Nicki loves it yeah I mean I
it was an acquired taste for sure like
where I at first when I tried it I was
like oh and then I was like kind of I'm
craving that again though and you mix it
with like fried rice or like
something else you don't just eat it
plain you just like put it on something
to fry rice yeah I think so it's more
like a sauce I think I know but it's
cold I don't like cold soup alright
let's talk about other things you're not
into like your turn offs in when you
were dating when you're in that dating
world or in previous relationships that
made you think like this isn't going to
be marriage I thought well first of all
I am a you know I'm not even bragging
about myself here I'm just like one of
those romantic dudes right I like I like
that [ __ ] okay so when I am in something
early I get excited and I'm like oh yeah
we'll go the distance we can do this
[ __ ] like all that kind of stuff right
but then like as the relationship goes
on you start to notice things but I
would lacquer over those things with
positive feelings anyway I'm the
projection of like the perfect like the
end the end I wanted this person to be
was what I was trying to do touch-ups on
like almost daily right like this part
we if we just fix this part then it
would be perfect so yes I was like okay
if we just make this part and this part
that it'll be perfect still but it got
to the point where I would take a deep
breath before walking through my own
door you know I'm saying like to see
this person
seal it together because we live
together so so and then it became like
one of those things where I was like
okay I'm pretty miserable when we're
together and we don't like she does like
she doesn't open up or talk about
interesting things at all so like her
like about herself or about like you
know it's there's no depth there so I
was like okay maybe I'll just try
watching all of the things that she
likes so I was like hey let's just treat
this and this is this is like before I
knew what an icky relationship could be
like I was like okay relationships to
work I'm gonna put in the work right now
whatever you would do if I wasn't here
you do it and I'll just experience it
with you because I'm here I know and so
they would watch their show like
whatever it was there was one called
skins
that show either I wasn't did not like
it never watched it it was very
different not for me okay scans fans
offend a lot of skins
controversial episode so I so I'm like
man this is just misery like the art
tastes do not align mm-hmm and then like
even like the things that she thought
was funny I didn't think was funny so
you were to match the match you kind of
were just like oh this person's perfect
in or right now oh no it's good like I
just couldn't help but notice but Casey
was just like I'm hearing enjoyed any
board too so I was like yeah so so so
that's when you you know if not for
thankfully this person cheating on me I
would have never let go I would have
latched on to this person and made that
should work because I thought relations
just work and that you had to put in the
work or you're quitting you know what I
recently found this triangle thing that
I posted on my stories recently I forgot
the other ones but there's this one
corner like if you're only in one corner
and not all doing all three then it's
bad right on each corner and one corner
is commitment only you end up having
empty love it's a triangle of commitment
intimation and you can have all three of
those in one relationship and it's a
pretty good relationship makes so much
sense one end of the spectrum or only
two out of the three like it creates a
disconnect yeah like if it's passionate
only its infatuation if it's intimacy
only it's just liking them like almost
like more like a friend than it is like
a partner and then if you're only on the
commitment side then it just becomes
like kind of like a family member
yeah I was coming to ask writer die
[ __ ] and so I didn't I didn't know what
a relationship could be like yet
I just knew what everyone said which is
that everything's work work work and I
saw my parents his own marriage not
being like the most kick-ass [ __ ] on the
earth and so I was like okay I you have
to suffer and the way the sitcoms
portray marriages to are like right
always a [ __ ] wife and the husband's
dumb you know they make a word yeah
beginning to fights and the make it work
so then when I go Nikki we had a rocky
start we did but we were projecting a
lot of our old relationships onto each
other because we had a very similar past
where it was like okay for me it was
like um I'm also a romantic and like we
were the same type of romantic we were
like [ __ ] and trying to impress the
[ __ ] out of each other when we first got
together but in my past relationships I
was always more romantic than them and I
felt like it would I got to the point
where I was like okay there's always
gonna be one person that's more romantic
that's more the chaser and I'm that
person like I'm just always gonna be the
one that's the more romantic person
because I've never met a match that like
reciprocated that part and so I think
when we got together we were both like
romantic and impressing each other but
we also projected the other parts like
well I'm gonna be them I was like oh
well I'm obviously more in love with him
than he is with me and he probably felt
the same way and and it just caused a
lot of turmoil because we were
projecting our old relationships yes and
so that but as we dug through that stuff
yeah it wasn't really about each other
that's when we understood each other and
having that mutual understanding meet
like the love language connection thing
is like rocket fuel for a relationship
like we have the best relationship I've
ever had in my life and it only gets
better I only love her more now yeah I
was just telling we're just on our
podcast I'll tell you you can check that
out thank you honestly like when I look
at our own wedding photos I'm like wow I
love her more now than I did then which
is crazy
yeah so that's and that's that's a hard
thing to I don't think a lot of people
get there yeah and I think that that's
like growth to an understanding and like
the more you get to know this person the
more you can get to fall in love with
this person and I think there's like a
notion that out there that seems to be a
very popular consensus that once you get
married it's just the passion goes away
becomes work you just it's like a job
you know you just have to make it work
but it doesn't have to be that way our
passion got incredibly higher after
marriage and I think because we became
even more of a team and you know what I
think it is I think you guys have been
putting in the work but you don't see it
as work it's like yeah it's like when
you love what you do is for a living you
don't feel like you actually work a day
in your life it's like that in your
relationship because you guys are
getting to know each other you love that
that the work that you're putting into
getting to know each other yes I was
just on Jay King is shout out and yeah
they we were talking about how I just
got to hang out with my best friend in a
beautiful place we've never been to
before in the Bahamas and that's what
makes it so much more fun and and that's
all watching together we love like
discovering new places and being like
well that was [ __ ] like when people are
hyping something up and we both look at
each other like are you into this like
if we're both they say we're we were on
a cruise or something which we've done
we both look at it at the same time and
were like we're over this [ __ ] the same
like I don't know the same fuse when you
know what else we have is the same smile
together each other great smile in
exchange glances and then we know and I
had to get my smile through old school
braces and it took freaking years they
were ugly they were in everyone's faces
I had to have rubber bands now there's a
much easier system in place it was all
transition yeah that's beautiful
transition but it's you know this year
you can straighten your teeth you could
and you could do it a much easier way
with candids clear aligners yeah which
unlike braces they're comfortable
removable and totally invisible so you
can transform your smile without anyone
noticing a thing and you don't have to
say step foot in a doctor's office
because you could do all this from home
of that this is awesome dude getting the
x-rays for at the orthodontist oh my god
this is the thing I hated the most
that nasty gooey yeah you putting your
mouth well candid they actually do this
thing where you mix the hoodies together
and it ends up being it's not like a
sticky like gooey kind of thing that's
disgusting
your mouth it's like this really nice
firm kind of putty kind of thing and
that's how you get your impressions oh
that's so cool yeah yeah um and doing
yourself there's actually 65% less than
braces too which is nice that's a lot
yeah I know right 65% on getting a nice
smile and you don't have to go to
doctors office and candid only works
with orthodontists they never work with
general dentists so that means your
treatment will be designed by an expert
in tooth with 20 years of experience on
average and if there's like a special
event coming up the average treatment
length is just six months so if you have
a wedding coming up this year or some
sort of you know like a big birthday
probably somewhere where you're gonna
take a lot of photos your teeth will be
ready and you'll start seeing results
way before then yeah you know that's
actually what I did right before our
wedding yeah I signed up to get clear
aligners and it was like in six months
done and your teeth look incredible yeah
- I wasn't good about wearing retainers
[Music]
incredible my voice is slowly coming
back from excuse me here dick the
website is also super easy to use I went
on there I was like I wish this was in
place when I was in high school because
I never would have to wear those dumb
braces for so long half my high school
career I had braces I'm still bitter
about it yeah so you can learn more
about candids process and get a
complimentary 3d scan of your teeth at
candid at a candid studio near you it's
a simplest freest way to get started so
if you're ready to take the first step
for a limited time you can get started
with $75 off a lot of money by using
code mood men candid co.com / mood
that's candid co.com / mood use code
mood for $75 off candid co.com / mood
code mood yeah yeah you're incredible
[ __ ] well how was your high school
career it was not great
on campaign mode yeah I know
campaign you wouldn't get it cuz you
don't play games I don't sorry
now you're gonna go cry and have
emotions no dudes group energy no but
you know what Mickey got to ask this to
Steve and I I didn't get to ask you
Casey though but uh-huh what was it then
that you decided about me to pursue me
to get for us to have a long-term
relationship because like you said like
you said we were trying to do a fling
thing I think you were seeing someone
else
- but then what was it between like me
and like the the see yeah I think for me
it was like I'd spent a couple of years
I well the
the girlfriend the the long-term
girlfriend before you I think she she
was like trying to be in the industry
and like you know modeling and all these
things and then like after her like you
know in the transition phase and like I
don't know even like before that
girlfriend - it's like I which is more
like I'm trying to be a filmmaker
photographer like whatever like I was
just like trying to get like the access
to girls were always kind of like
they're also in the entertainment thing
like they were always trying to be in
the showbiz and and that brings a
certain like a different kind of
direction in the relationship to it
there's like this work that work and
that work yeah I do like fake stuff yeah
I could benefit from you being in my
life where we work together
yeah I remember you were dating like a
singer or something
and then to just use you for music
videos yeah exactly like there was just
like we can I can build a portfolio you
know you know any producers or like you
know like there was like a lot of this
kind of like network you're like I'll
choose someone that's not in the
entertainment you were the first person
I started seeing that wasn't in the
entertainment business didn't want to be
in it and to give some context that for
those of you I don't know I was working
in a hospital we met so completely
different career yeah and and and I
think the fact that you were a mom to I
think was something that was
subconsciously very sexy about that
because I think it was very comforting
to meet someone that had that that liked
the home life or like the had a home
life you know I think everyone else that
you meet and especially in the early 20s
everyone's trying to go out every night
trying to network trying to have fun get
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] and then and then do it all over
again and I don't know there she came
with a turnkey home life double nurturer
then because your whole work you're like
nurturing people it's like sick patients
and things really like at a hospital and
then you come home and you're nurture
your kid true work with patients but
yeah does have that vibe it's that
nurture there I think that was really
really enticing for me and like just
felt way more comfortable to open up to
you I think like I think with the other
people it was like I still need to keep
my like industry face on and like we're
all cool we're all too cool to really be
vulnerable and I think with you it's
just like having a kid and like you know
I don't know there's like this
discomfort and knowing that you know
you're on that program of trying to
settle down even though you say you
weren't but like yeah actually was it I
was just like listen I just got out of
an sanely serious relationship a month
ago about as serious as it gets that say
yeah like engage serious and then so I
was just like listen no but then you
kept
suing and I couldn't deny my feelings
either so I'm like damn it [ __ ] oh geez
[Laughter]
single folk out there that might be
looking to date and they're like you
know I'm ready to settle down and get a
serious relationship what are some of
the things that were like the biggest
turn offs like I know you you spoke a
little bit about the bush Steve oh right
that's true but it was like a wiry
unkempt you know I heard it's kind of
coming back disaster area like Chewbacca
yeah like just too much yes so it's like
that not like oh like you know Chewie
kept kept it nice and neat I don't think
he did yeah no he did not
he looks combed and kinda like forest
gums beard when he was running yes
through the country kind of like okay
how about Tom Hanks in castaway oh yeah
all over very character traits or
personality traits like when you're on a
date mostly just in the bush no yeah of
course well you did mention he'll for
you you were attracted to her being able
to go deep like in conversations and
yeah and we were friends already and
that helped a lot too like being friends
with made me well we weren't best
friends yet no no but now but now we are
but but we were well I was ready to be
best friends immediately we were friends
already right so going into it we had
like cheat codes almost it was like yeah
you guys knew each other for a longer
time and helpful yeah it did that's true
cuz our first thing it's never have any
awkwardness I'll just jump right into
like hanging out conversation like we've
got to have deeper conversations yeah
and that was what's fun about it right
and like the more we uncovered it's like
oh is my favorite sketch of all time oh
so we not our own sketches but like SNL
sketches yeah we had our favorites
kakie
[Laughter]
we see that's what I'm saying though
some people are like that yeah really
with people during holidays and they
pull their own videos and TV no please
get me out of here
yeah so we're both not like that and
that's part of it too right like finding
your match like I know a lot of
Hollywood ish climber people and they
can't wait to put on their own videos
and their partner is like yeah this is
the best then they can go be happy in a
little bubble together just I don't want
to hang out I think it is it is very
much like common interests and love
languages exactly that's what I found to
be something to look out for because
it's from people on the same love
language it doesn't matter what their
common interests are anymore like after
a while they cannot speak the same
language on a deeper level and they're
just constantly disappointed with each
other right and they're not even meaning
to write I could do something that's
nice for you but that's not nice in your
love language so therefore in one you're
not the other to me and so it's not
appreciated yeah I did have an ex that
was he's the love language he showed me
for love which I didn't get till after
we broke up was gift-giving and I didn't
give a [ __ ] about gifts like and I mean
when you think of someone in need it's
nice like I wasn't like oh [ __ ] your
gift but like it's nice I was like oh
that's really nice and that's all it
went to like it didn't go deep in my
heart like like this is really love me
it was just like oh that was thoughtful
of him and so I would always be confused
in fights when he's like I do everything
to show you that I love you and you
don't see it that way but this dude
never spent time with me and my love
language was quality time so I was like
you never show me love I feel like you
don't even like me yeah and and so we'd
always fight about that and it didn't
become clear to me until I learned about
love languages way later than like oh he
did think he was showing me love cuz the
way he expressed it was so much
different like gifts is my zero bottom I
don't get gift-giving you there like
when out of the five love like I look at
that one I'm like that seems kind of I
don't know like not too easy you know
you got to spend a couple dollars and
buy something and some other person
it's Lucan yeah sentimental fan shows
that you're thinking of them and that
you listening exactly you're making them
feel important lovers out there I got
your back for those those people but yet
to me it was just like oh that's
thoughtful yeah done like in one ear out
the other wasn't love to me that's
actually well we recently have been
discovering that's what I'm saying like
we've been married for two years almost
three now and now we're getting it yeah
we've been together for seven years
almost eight and this whole this past
year so 2019 was a rough one the
roughest we got out of it like with you
know the light at the end of the tunnel
tender feelings yeah but yeah it really
was about learning each other's
languages and because this whole time we
were just like ah you just why don't you
listen or like why aren't you receiving
this and it was always like
miscommunicated that's true I'm an
access service person like that's what I
that's my love language going outward
and then for you it was quality time
yeah and so like for me it's like well
I'm I'm making dinner I breakfast you
know like coffee in the morning it takes
hours to do dinner you know I'm like
come on here we go that's and then like
I'm like setting up you know like and
then that whole time that you're away
doing those things I'm like he's not
spending any time with me doesn't love
me register the kitchen the whole time
whenever together so we never had time
to do quality time right or so then once
we discovered each other's languages
like we were trying to do it like four
so for you to receive love is words of
affirmation and so and then so I started
noticing that you are also giving me
that and I was just like oh my gosh this
is the language like how do I speak this
language it's like Chinese to me which I
tried learning and is really hard like I
don't know I don't I didn't know how to
give that to you and I guess right now
we're still trying to figure it out but
how do you make that adjustment I find
that so fascinating that you're now that
you understand those languages now
you're trying to crack the code after we
tell them what shampoo they're using
because I think it's very important to
everyone's loved language that we smell
nice and feel nice and function of
beauty is actually the one I'm obsessed
with I've been obsessed with this for a
year now I love that it's all customized
everything they do it like you get to go
to the website and you take a little
quiz for question quiz it's so short and
then they get to know and I don't know
about you two but I never really took
into consideration like hair type like
buy in the right gym yeah my hair
tighter did I I didn't think of that
about it that way but yeah they have you
fill out the survey of like what your
hair type is and you know what you're
looking for in a shampoo volume anti
frizz you know shine whatever it is and
you you fill it all out and then you
also get to pick the scent which yeah
really awesome cuz they have a really
really really good sense the one I
picked was eucalyptus cuz it's so
relaxing and distressing and I found
like in the shower I like to just
distress yeah and have that and then if
you if you're not into a dye or a
fragrance they also offer that without a
dye or fragrance free yeah but if you
want yours to be colorful it's cute it
really is thank you I picked a black one
oh you did I like the black the only one
I pick the blue one so live your best
hair life in 2020 the Internet's
top-rated customized haircare brand with
over 30,000 five-star customer reviews
and Counting curly straight natural
process they have every every type of
formula for every hair out there and
even for hair goals - oh yeah yeah if
you want whatever we want your hair to
look like this year what type of hair
you want this yeah or like if you're
suffering from like split ends or like
dry scalp or whatever they try to help
you out with all that oh and what's cute
and a really nice touch is the products
are so personalized your name is even
printed on the bottle so it says cute it
says function of Li mo it's like house
of Lena why don't you put green last
name is Li mo so plus function of beauty
is vegan
they never use sulfates parabens flat
taste I don't know how to they'd only
use that thing philosophes mineral oils
or other harmful ingredients and to get
started right now you can go to function
of beauty.com / big mood to take your
four-part hair profile quiz and save 20%
off your first order don't spend another
minute on hair misery go to function of
beauty calm / big mood to let them know
that we sent you yeah
let's function of beauty.com / big mood
so tell us how the [ __ ] you got out of
your love language situation yeah how do
you adjust that I don't know mindfulness
are you like yeah okay right now I was
gonna do this but now I'm gonna do this
yeah there's a lot of like being present
anything for me right now it's like I
don't I never used to like pick up on
moments where we could have the bids
were never able to recognize the bids
what sleep like a bit is like Oh like
for example him making me a coffee like
that's a bid of love like he's like so
he's offering yeah I know now give me
something in return
click watch it now or like appreciate it
or something like recognizing it that
person is trying to show you love yeah
but for me it totally is like constantly
being present because sometimes like
even though we've been doing really
great recently like sometimes I'll kind
of get lazy or whatever it is like I'm
stuck in whatever it is I'm like
thinking about and I kill come around
and I'll revert to like my old ways
which were the toxic ways in our
relationship where like he's you know
you you're for Casey it's really
important to have like a pleasant tone
and so sometimes like if I'm thinking
about something else like I won't have
that Pleasant tone because I'm
frustrated over like some work thing or
whatever and then I'll throw it at him
and then he'll get upset and we're I'm
like oh wait hold on I caught myself
let's talk about that
that's not the intention and so we've
been learning how to use the muscle of
communication and like and then
understanding to what's giving the other
person the benefit of the doubt that
like okay well that wasn't done out of
malice or whatever
I think that's something that has
shifted majorly in our marriage because
before we used to see each other as like
enemies because we were so hurt from
like a past stuff that's for sure for me
too it's like just finding ways to have
fun and our relationship was a big thing
too it's like I think for me like having
having been together for six years it
was like I mean it just make this work
you know like our lives are so
intertwined with work and all these
things like the idea of starting over
doesn't seem like a good idea so we're
just gonna have to like stick it through
till we die yeah what like the only idea
of like happiness which is to make it
work and so then it's just like what's
functional okay cool I'll pick up the
kid you do that I run this errand to
that and then it's just like as long as
it's functional if it's working in part
yeah then it seems like it's good enough
yeah but but then it yeah we lacked a
house with plumbing electricity
yeah we're killing it but we weren't
having fun like we weren't like actually
having conversations where were we were
like involved with each other like in
being president next day like we weren't
even looking at each other of a house
but not a home right how do you come to
this kind of a monumental shift like
what is there a moment is there like a
series of moment there was a from the
way I see it it was a good year of a lot
of work being done so we're both going
to therapy reaching out to our friends
and like talking to you guys getting
advice and like really understanding how
we can view this relationship from a
different perspective than that what we
were viewing it from and then like
learning how to stop doing the same
dance so from for me personally I don't
think it was like this one like aha
moment it was a lot of like tiny little
aha moments that built up to where we're
at for me that's true I think for me
it's uh exploring a beam I mean I think
it takes a lot of courage to to like dig
down into your past and like try and
analyze why you are the way you are
because I think for a long time I've
kind of never from within you
like it's like so what like you know I
grew up this way and like you know like
I have my head on straight you know I've
done gotten this far you know it's like
you don't really take the time to think
like well maybe there's something
there's like a trauma or like there's
something darker from your past or a
misunderstanding from your past that
really is both sure of like what's going
on in our relationship you know like
something we've picked up from our
parents or like you know certain social
situations in the past that really
caused a scar yeah you carry that hurt
with you but you you we don't ever want
to revisit it though because it hurts so
much and so you kind of just suppress it
you suppress it so you don't even never
think to look there anymore and this
year I think I finally opened that book
up and been forced to like face our own
mirrors and be like okay so what's going
on in there that's so awesome and
healthy that you guys are doing that and
I also don't think that you're
completely deplaned because I do think
that our generation at least was not
raised with like knowing about love
languages or actually that we had men
are from Mars Women are from Venus which
basically says like hey you guys are
from two different planets he'll never
like understand each other but yeah like
so having knowing about love languages
now I feel like each generation has
helped the next generation the best they
could but our parents were very much
like you got to make it work marriage
works you know yeah they're about the
commitment part which is great but yeah
those other two were maybe not apparent
and everybody's upbringing and now that
we have this new information and like
the most current psychology and the way
that people operate in relationships and
what makes a healthy relationship it's
really nice for this next generation
going forward you'll know about love
languages you'll be able to talk about
that on date so be able to open up and
be vulnerable a lot earlier than maybe
we were able to when we were you know in
our young 20 I'm seeing a direct like
the direct effect because you know since
we have Isaac he's 11 about to be 12 he
and then this past year like I've tried
to be not like obviously like fully open
like oh my god you know all of our
problems not like that crazy but like
just really surface things just so he's
aware like hey you know daddy and I are
kind of going through some stuff you see
it
trying to treat him as like so idiot I
can't see what's happening so yeah like
I was like we were very mindful of
communicating with him and letting him
see and then also not just the bad stuff
but then once we were able to work
things out like now we don't hide our
discussions anymore because it was
brought to our attention like you know
you should if he's seeing the ugly he
should also see how you resolve it yes
so then he can learn how to approach his
interpersonal relationships and how to
better communicate and like confront
problems and that includes bringing
family into your problems to men if you
call your mom about how much your
husband sucks your boyfriend sucks and
they don't or not and they're not there
for the resolution you just hurt your
relationship exact guess what because
now the mom is gonna remember that and
isn't gonna let it go because they
weren't there for the [ __ ] right and
that's something that I've really
realized a lot too cuz even just
recently like I hit up the girls yeah
because like usually I'll vent to them
and just tell them like oh my god even
with you like you know like this was my
fault I reach out to for the bad I've
noticed like oh my god they need to know
the good too because then they only had
yeah exactly is damaging all the
relationship so then I recently like hit
up the girls and I told Casey to and I'm
like yeah I told them all the good stuff
yeah it was so cute I was like yeah this
is so healthy like cuz yeah it does help
us to know the full picture right
because if we only hear the bad and
we're like we're trying to be there for
you and then we don't hear when like
things get resolved or like the good
things the progress that's being made we
only hear the next time that it's bad
yeah well uh Thank You Nikki for
conveying the message to me because you
did not and so I thought that things
were just as bad as when we were talking
about a month or two ago and so then I
and then finally we're finally all
hanging again cuz we have all been sick
and then we'd all been on the break and
holidays and New Year's just this week
yeah yeah and I was like oh man we're
killing it and I'm like what you guys
guys it's not my responsibility you guys
need to get your own guys chat together
do not have your own text messaging
machines we're good
people they say get back and forth you
tried texted Bart and Joe I don't want
to let me know how many words they
respond to you with my text group is
different and I chose it okay Joe is out
of town and it's just but we've been so
that's why I have been sitting here
learning like guys talk to each other
and the girls he's gonna fill me I guess
what she didn't automatically assume
that you guys isn't it fun that we all
get to like hang out together work
together
I could even fill you in on someone that
I'm friends with and that you're friends
with also sure yes you were telling me
how like I'm you didn't write us off
they're like you're you you kind of like
you know what though like because okay
last year we had a lot of lows and then
each lo we thought damn this is
rock-bottom and then we get lower oh
[ __ ] no wait this is run the ovens are
like I don't know how much longer I
could hold on to the range from this
clip it's pretty it was pretty amazing
also to what I'm hearing from you guys
like I was not hearing like because we
can do this so all I'm doing is okay how
do I support you as you do this not only
hey friend you can do it yeah yeah
you're not a quitter to do that I'm
gonna listen to what my friends want and
what their intentions are and try to
understand what their what is motivating
them and what didn't give them the most
happiness and then how they're back yeah
yeah so I was hearing from both of you
like holy [ __ ] this is suffering for me
and I'm going okay then that's why when
you say like yeah I wrote it off I was
like dang I don't think that this is I
don't know if this is the best make
sense I'm you have both sides of the
puzzle here and they're both saying the
same thing I mean it's obviously you
include that it's gonna let
can we transition you guys into freedom
and happiness yeah your talks off the
light I think you guys brought a lot of
perspective in terms of like like trying
to work on on like what we want you know
like that was like the verbage a lot of
times like what do you Casey what do you
want forget the relationship what do you
want and it's really helpful yeah and
then it's like oh cool like I don't need
to always like slave a work for work
towards this relationship I just need to
work towards myself and what I wanted
happened to align with the relationship
that's that's the path to take and
that's kind of like what it was it was
like I don't need to worry about Tiff's
so much I don't need to worry about the
relationship so much what do I need I
need to be healthy it's kinda like the
whole like airplane thing like put your
life vest doing that before you were not
doing that you're not in the same world
from my experience I felt the same and
I'm just like when is he gonna show up
what the [ __ ] just not talking the same
or speaking the same language but I'm so
glad that you guys were able to figure
that out and like it's such a better
tone for the year for your relationships
our work or our marriages work and stuff
I think that is what they're talking
about is like that that baseline
understanding is something that a lot of
people haven't figured out yet and it's
and it is it does seem like the worst
most awful work because if you haven't
figured that foundation out yet you're
gonna constantly have the same issues
come up again and again and again and
wonder why your partner just doesn't get
it
and really quick to you know in our
culture like you were saying Nikki you
watch the sitcom and they always point
out how different we are
oh man and women is so hard figure I
could never speak the language
understand I don't know we have our guy
friends and a girl for instance [ __ ]
about our you know I could be myself
again but but we're really what we
should all be focused on cuz it's not
that hard if you can you could oh you
have to do is understand that not all
women and not all men are the same like
and if you can understand your person
and if you can just work your ass off to
try to understand them then it becomes
easier but
instead of pointing out there's nothing
more less productive than sitting there
in trying to have a relationship with
somebody and just pointing out all day
how different you are
hey women are so different hey men are
so different don't even worry about
trying to figure this [ __ ] out it's too
hard right there's crazy wait Steve so
it's almost like you're saying we're all
individuals oh all races are not this
way all religious are not this way all
people are not this way it's almost like
individuals have their own feelings and
analogies and values and so that's what
we should all I think focus on is not
how different we are but how similar we
are
and how beautiful that is yeah and then
that's when you form because what Cayce
said I bring [ __ ] energy in the group
thanks laundering way no but that's
something that allowed men to open up
where they're not supposed to right
because they're a culture [ __ ] so so
that's that's what matters right not
what society tells you is manly but what
you find in your group and being able I
think being able to [ __ ] express
yourself is manly yeah and what you want
me do so that that's my team have a
stance like you said in the very
beginning that stance of how you would
like to operate in a relationship and
making it clear is so important it is
and it is sexy to be like wow I know
exactly what this man wants I know and
he knows what I want and now we can just
better serve each other exactly and then
like he knows what he wants
yes that's the same [ __ ] ever so don't
forget to check how much show ass Lords
where can we find you I heard there
might be screenings of this project
called danger boys with UC Irvine next
Friday night I don't know what probably
coming out much before
I mean much after then Gus you you can
go to a website that I don't know if the
top my head
oh sure I think it's good JK f at
gmail.com also you can go to the danger
boys Instagram danger boys six to six
and we'll probably have the deep info on
how to find a screening near you yeah
but that's so exciting guys I'm so proud
of you well it's it's legit actually
funny thank you and I don't say that a
bunch about a lot of projects but they
it actually is really really really good
really about Steve's work other than
this follow their danger boy 66 on
Instagram follow all their social media
all the links are of everything we've
talked about will be in the description
and any last words guys just how
different we all are is not that
interesting yeah yeah well nailed it
there we go and check out my show
asteroids being the absolute [ __ ] outta
[ __ ] and crushing [ __ ] and be sure to
subscribe on our YouTube channel we are
all gonna cross Bosnia in 2020 and crush
[ __ ] by rating us 5 stars on iTunes
that would be amazing awesome we love
you guys thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time